foreign
[Music]
well that was
I was pink
welcome to another episode of fun day
service my friends is where you guys
come to get your spiritual cleansing and
we talk about whatever you suggest for
me to talk about and honestly once again
I said I was going to create content
again so here I am
what do I do with these hands I just
this is an awkward Funday service is
going to be uh I guess it's just going
to be videos like this you know when I
was going through my mind about creating
content again I started kind of going
too far ahead of myself I was like all
right I'm gonna get this whole team set
up so we can start shooting these videos
and do that but at the same time I have
to manage my time and see what I'm doing
because once again if you guys don't
know opened up that matcha store jumbee
out in Waikiki at the Royal Hawaiian
make sure you check that out secret
society has their fall winter line
coming out so a few weeks ago a couple
weeks ago was it a week ago I saw this
video that honestly when I saw it I
didn't want to pay any mind to it right
because we live in a society now where
we see types of content like this all
the time
um
Chinese konichiwa Argentino 10 years
now listen to me years ago what I would
do is that I would see a video like this
and I'd probably go off right because
you know this is this was a roasting
channel so I would roast the [ __ ] out of
somebody who does something really
stupid now when I saw this like I don't
know if it's because I'm getting tired
of this [ __ ] or whether I continue
to see things like this so I'm just
desensitized but that's really not the
case I had to sit here and think about
this because you know his video in and
of itself didn't offend me any more than
what anybody else creates online when it
comes to [ __ ] [ __ ] on Asian
people it wasn't necessarily him that I
want to talk about or things that he's
done it was the comments in the comments
section on Twitter and on YouTube that
[ __ ] bothered me one of the things
that I really wanted to discuss was the
concept of calling this kid racist right
and you know in 2022 and 2021 one of the
hottest things that everybody was doing
was labeling anybody racist if they said
anything distasteful whether it was a
lack of Education or somebody who was
just culturally insensitive
um immediately if you felt a certain way
about it you could just go you're a
racist go [ __ ] off nobody should ever
speak to you again now when I look at
this kid and I look at this video and I
see this content do I think that he's
racist no but is he racially insensitive
and from this video did he lack a
certain amount of respect for Asian
culture a hundred [ __ ] percent and
there's absolutely no way in denying
that and to be honest with you a lot of
people fall into that [ __ ] category
and one of the [ __ ] dumbest arguments
that I kept reading in the comments was
well how is he racist towards Asian
people when you know he talks about
anime and he has Asian friends listen
here if you don't get your I got one
black friend named Devonte that plays
basketball so I don't hate black people
having sorry ass [ __ ] excuse ass on
the [ __ ] going out of here I don't want
to hear [ __ ] that's what you sound like
yeah sounds familiar well I love myself
some 50 Cent so I love Black Culture
shut up shut up you know I thought that
we were getting to this point where I
remember the last two to three years
people were really [ __ ] with this
concept of like listen we can't take all
the the great and dope [ __ ] about
certain cultures and then leave
everything else behind I thought that's
the way that we were on but apparently
not it only applies to you but it
doesn't apply the other way around and I
don't really [ __ ] with that you know
when I really thought about it the most
disappointing thing about this whole
situation isn't really this kid right
because look at his brand he's a cloud
chaser the kid acts crazy does stupid
[ __ ] and thus his content is created by
you
the viewers out there y'all love
watching him do stupid [ __ ] so I expect
somebody who continues to act like a
[ __ ] dumbass to continue to do stupid
things that's not really where I'm
surprised right I want people to think
about this question why is it that
almost every time without fail when it
comes to a situation like this of people
spitting and [ __ ] on Asian people
and our culture that is always on us to
take the [ __ ] joke for some reason
when we stand up for ourselves and we
say hey you're going too far
it's our fault
how
how
is it that when we stand up for
ourselves it's an issue what in the [ __ ]
did it become appropriate in society did
The Gaslight Asian Americans or just
Asian people in general to make us feel
that whenever we stand up for ourselves
that we should just shut the [ __ ] up
that we are the problem that we can't
take the joke listen I'm not on my high
horse right we already know like
especially when it comes to the stand-up
world we all make racial jokes all the
time that's like our [ __ ] right we get
it but there's like cultural Nuance in
it when you heard or saw this video
where was the joke was it creative did
it bring an Insight or was that you just
doing these old Asian racist jokes from
40 to 50 [ __ ] years ago once again
I'm not saying that you're racist but we
do have to address the fact that what
you did was it highly highly racially
insensitive in the last like 40 to 50
years I'm pretty sure the Asian
Community has been pretty uh together
about not saying ching chong and you
know mislabeling our languages and
[ __ ] lumping us all into one [ __ ]
group and I don't want to hear this
stupid [ __ ] excuse of re-fortifying
your bad behavior when it comes to my
culture by saying like well uh I had
this uh bad experience or I've heard of
Asian people disrespecting other
people's culture so it's okay don't
[ __ ] Gaslight me [ __ ] sit the [ __ ]
down you don't get to justify your
terrible habits and disrespecting my
culture by picky backing off of somebody
else's struggles we are talking about
the person at hand and holding people
accountable for what they do as an
individual when people bring up the
topic of age of holding people
accountable and I can't believe I have
to actually explain this when they say
well he was 17 and he didn't know better
at the time we're talking about
something that's in the past that was
addressed at the time and that person
throughout time has been able to show
that they have gotten better or don't
hold those negative or bad ideals yes
he's 17 but he's 17 right now so it
should be addressed what are you on
about are you that dumb
are you you don't get a pass because
you're young that's not how that works
none of us do it's understandable that
he's doing stupid things at the age of
17 because of his age but it doesn't
admonish him from the things that he's
doing right now and it's not how it
[ __ ] works [ __ ] when I was
young it would have been great if I
could just walk up slap a [ __ ]
in the face and be like oopsies I'm 17.
but David he apologized in a couple of
his streams if you really took that
apology as a real my god dude at least
back in the day when Logan Paul did the
the the videotape of the Japanese man
hanging in the suicide forest even
though his [ __ ] apology video was
hilarious at least it was like somewhat
of a sincere apology or to the best of
his abilities the idea that this young
man said in his apology was oh I I uh
when I said or whatever that was like
the Chinese name that my that my Chinese
friend gave me and that's all I was
trying to say and that's his apology and
y'all [ __ ] believe that [ __ ] listen
I've I've given up on Humanity literally
I I don't [ __ ] care anymore I can't
tell you what you should or shouldn't be
offended by right that's not my place
because a lot of things that Asian
people are offended by I'm not offended
by and I defend your right to go ahead
and feel the way that you do because
that's none of our place but when you
allow somebody to use your culture as a
prop
especially a culture that they are not a
[ __ ] part of you're just an accessory
to that hate you're there a [ __ ] you're
not [ __ ] cool we understand that
there's jokes with racism you know we
kind of keep it within this our small
circle and we'll throw race jokes at
each other and we laugh all the [ __ ]
time but listen
there was no cultural Nuance to that
[ __ ] and I'll use Russell Peters as a
great example right when he was you know
making jokes about Chinese people or
whatever whatnot there was cultural
Nuance to a jokes that we knew about
there was inside jokes that we related
to this is not one of those situations
so don't compare [ __ ] apples and
oranges we're not [ __ ] dumb listen
let's just call it what it is we've seen
this [ __ ] a million times and it happens
a lot with Black Culture people love
everything that it is to be quote
unquote a black American when it comes
to like the culture the clothes the
slang the sayings everything about it
but when it comes to taking the full
package they're like nah we're good they
get to pick and choose what they want
and it's happening to us too but nobody
wants to speak up against it because
gaslighting Asian people is an
acceptable thing to do a lot of people
now they like to use this term allyship
they go oh well if you ain't a [ __ ]
Ally you out of this [ __ ] group guess
what allyship works both ways
it works both ways
if we are to support everybody else you
are to support us too if we respect what
you say then you respect us back
that's as simple as it gets there's no
if and [ __ ] buts about it if it is
unacceptable for us to tell people what
other people should accept in their
cultures you don't get to do that to us
well that ends this episode of fun day
service I love every single one of you I
want to go ahead and do more of these
videos and once again I hate looking at
[ __ ] like this but this is something
for us to think about especially as a
community and if you're not a part of
the Asian Community please think about
this as well why is it acceptable to
tell us to shut the [ __ ] up when we talk
about issues that affect us on the daily
and I know a lot of people are going to
say this well David didn't you say uh
tell simulu that he was you know over
exaggerating when it came to Asian
topics 100 because
I've already told you the reasons why
all right I don't want to hear that I
don't hate that guy [ __ ] are
like oh he's living in your head
rent-free [ __ ] I'm living in his
head rent-free all right see the size of
that goddamn thing [ __ ] all of us
come moving there and nobody would know
the difference that [ __ ] is huge look
I'm just making jokes okay I'll stop
anyways guys uh genius brain podcast
every Sundays at 12 p.m check out the
[ __ ] fashion Basics clothing line
secret society that's
s-e-r-t-s-o-c-i-e-t-y.com people out in
Hawaii check out my matcha shop June B
Waikiki let's go I love myself I'm
promoting myself I [ __ ] with you kiss me
on the mouth and life is what you make
it take what you deserve let's go for
bro see y'all next time